so you have one of the cooler ideas I
did of any of the 30 under 30 people I
went through this myself I graduate from
college I got a job in New York City and
you get raped by a broker trying to find
just an affordable place to live and
you're coming in and solving that
problem
definitely the nice thing about the
business thus far is that we're solving
problems really for two groups one is
young graduates that are relocating from
campuses around the world to cities
around the world the other group of
people are young brokers who are trying
to jump start their careers get
experience in the rental market start
making some money so they can move into
sales and build up a long-term client
base so we've kind of found a way to
really solve two major issues for two
major groups of people in this economy
which I think has been probably one of
the most rewarding parts about this
business how long has it been going now
so April 2010 is great if a patient so
we're a year and three quarters and so
we're not at the two-year mark yet which
is great to have moving this quickly
it's been exhausting but you know being
an entrepreneur it's going to be
exhausting but lifestyle times are
alleged right and how what sort of scale
are you and how many cities now so we're
in 20 cities in the US and we're in ten
cities in Europe and I'd say that in the
US we're really seeing most our traffic
in New York Chicago Boston Philly Miami
in Atlanta
okay I'm as well as the cities in Texas
Austin Dallas San Antonio and then as
for Europe London's really are our hub
now that just so everybody knows the
name of the company is the next step
Realty and you co-founded this with a
co-founder of my partner Belton Baker
right who had the idea with me was you
know we were both equally kind of in the
same conversation right and had the idea
together we act on it together to launch
it together and he now serves as our
director of Campus Outreach okay so he's
in charge of our College marketing which
is obviously a huge part of our business
because that trust traffic to the site
so it's been extremely beneficial to
have him continue to be supportive and
continue to be a primary resource and
company now where did you get the the
capital to to launch the site that you
have backers you have investors you have
VC yeah how does that work so there's
lots of different opportunities to raise
money in this
market we chose originally to go the
family and friends route right which was
basically we put an email together that
was a nondisclosure agreement
non-compete and then the business plan
write the business plan we stayed up all
night writing it was 35 pages long
we sent it to 20 people individually who
we write 35 pictures every night one
night one night otherwise you should
work for me I have it I wrote three my
pages for one night when I don't think
and I've never written that much since
actually funny story I lost that
business plan three times that night I
finally wrote the final one which was
like 12 pages was the winner because all
the fluff was removed right right now
having done your business as you know
that all economy um so we sent this out
to how many things 20 family and friends
that family brings is a term people
using the investor community you're not
actually talking people are related
tours so sense of people who I thought
would be there interesting this idea
because they're looking for startups
have backgrounds in real estate or
looking for real estate investments or
would know people who are in those first
two categories we got someone in the
hook in the first week we sat down to a
dinner with them which they were I think
incredibly moved by and moved by the
long-term vision we had right for both
graduates and for the real estate market
and you know they wrote some 19,000 hour
check on the spot Wow and we use that
for almost a year to build up who's in
the internet world you can start these
things sort of cheaply sure sure and we
only have a second year left and you
said something really interesting just a
second ago and I want to ask you about
that is that you said they were moved by
the fact that it was a long term plan it
wasn't like you weren't just trying to
do this and cash out and make us some
money and buy a Porsche you wanted you
want to build a company and to you is
that with what success means or is
success something else what do you
measure yourself against so I mean let
me just try to separate questions so the
first question is really what's the
long-term vision where and that answer
that is if you look at a company like
Corcoran or Sotheby's their approach to
real estate from day one has been let's
target and this works in bold market
right their approach has been let's
target wealthy consumers who are buying
expensive homes with a list of
properties there will be the buyer
representative in this market I think
spending your time prospecting those
people is a bad strategy so we've
decided to instead is reach those same
group people the same CEO
right people that will be billionaires
people that will be leaders in this
country in this economy target them
right in the end of college when they
the first Department right have a strong
brand loyalty program that encourage
them to continue working with you over
time so you help them at a time when
they need it
with easy convenient affordable access
to apartments and then continue to stay
in touch with them for the idea to go
more success yeah more apartments bigger
apartment purchases right homes in the
Hamptons after retirement and palm beach
whatever they're doing so in that way I
think we're building a good Network from
the ground up as for our success I
measure success for this company I'm for
you I'm much a much more interested in
you personally how do you measure
success at a personal level I mean I you
know I think that I was watching
actually the other night Larry King's
the dinner with the Kings and he had
people like Conan O'Brien and he has
this question of them what do you guys
think of success how do you feel of
being successful they said the reason
that I think we are successful is
because we never look at ourselves
instead we're successful because it's a
daily endeavor it's a new project it's a
constant upkeep it so it's almost kind
of you know what's next
and so for me the way that I'll measure
that over time is just if we're
accomplishing our goals right now our
goals are to expand to more colleges
more cities and help more college
graduates find apartments around the
world